hello everyone and welcome back for a
brand new episode of the witching hour
I am peri number off I'm sitting across
from my co-host Hallie foul show but the
important thing right now is we are
joined by a very special guest we have
Mick Garris in the house right now I
feel like I needed to do some sort of
like bigger T up and list off a whole
bunch of credits but I don't think I
know what to start with so I'm just
gonna tell you guys that you're
specifically here this week promoting
nightmare cinema which is due in select
theaters and on VOD on June 21st so
right up top that's what we're talking
about today but we're also going to talk
about a whole bunch of other things
anything you like thanks for having me
I love hearing about how everybody
gotten into the industry where the love
came from and when I was doing just a
little bit of light reading online one
of the things that crossed my eye that
you had started out with was a
connection to Star Wars and I want to
hear more about that opportunity
well my first I had been doing
journalism and for a while it was music
journalism and I was interviewing
rock-and-roll stars and writing reviews
about that then my interest turned more
to film and I started writing a bunch of
scripts that nobody ever saw and that's
probably a good thing and I was working
at Tower Records as a night manager in
Westwood and I'd heard through a friend
that there was a job opening at Star
Wars which had just come out and I went
and met with them and I didn't realize
it was for it was basically to be a
receptionist answer phone hello Star
Wars may I help you and I got the job
and it was 150 dollars a week and it
allowed me to do things like operate
r2d2 on the personal appearances
including the Oscars that year my first
and last time a team
ever and certain to be the last time but
yeah it was a beginning a humble
beginning of a hundred and fifty dollars
a week but playing with r2d2 and being
his personal manager is actually not the
first time this week I've heard of one
of somebody's first opportunities being
at Star Wars so just I don't know I was
talking to Matthew Wood who is a Academy
Award nominated sound editor and he just
faxed his resume to them one day and I
believe he started as a video game
tester over there and he's a good job
he's stuck with the franchise ever since
so you know we got these big franchises
out there that we're thankful for
because they helped get certain
individuals more opportunities after
yeah so 40 years ago that's so awesome
there it was yeah that was my my toe in
the water yeah so how did I know that
it's quite a journey
but the condensed version of going from
operating r2d2 to getting your first
directing gig
they were basically unrelated I was
doing spec screenplays and the lacked
with my journalism I also started doing
an interview show the first paid TV
channel in Los Angeles was called the Z
channel they were here before HBO and
Showtime and I went to them with an idea
of doing an interview show similar to
the podcast I do now where I would
interview the people who made the films
that we would show and I suggested a
show specifically about the science
fiction fantasy and horror genre and so
they said that sounds like a good idea
and you know triple digit salary
to do a hundred dollars a show I they
would give me a list of their upcoming
films and I would say which ones I
thought would be good and who I might be
able to get so amazingly I got John
Carpenter I got tobe Hooper I got Steven
Spielberg I got William Friedkin to do a
little 15 minute interview show that
would run before the movies and this
cable system ran in Beverly Hills and
the west side so people in the industry
saw it
and so that
was the beginning there that gave me
entree the ability with my writing to
get an agent and eventually I got jobs
doing publicity first at Avco embassy
where Joe Dante had just made the Howlin
John Carpenter had just made the fog
David Cronenberg had just made scanners
so I got to do specialized publicity
genre publicity where I'd go to
conventions and genre magazines and the
things and do making us because I'd do
it cheaper than anybody else and taught
myself how to put pieces of time
together and make a narrative out of
where there was not one before so
eventually I was able to get an agent
and I was doing the making of The
Goonies in Astoria Oregon which at the
time was the suicide capital of the
world and was interviewing Spielberg who
knew me from the Z channel interview who
said oh you must do a lot of these
things and I said well I'm trying not to
I'm you know this is I'm not
recommending this is how you do it
but because we knew each other and under
the circumstances and we're setting up
lights and stuff he said you know we're
looking for writers for a new show we're
doing called amazing stories when he
heard that I was a writer and it turned
out that at the same time their
development people had read a spec
script of mine that my agent had
submitted and the coverage was really
good the last the line was hire this man
and so I was the first person hired to
write a script for amazing stories and
that's where it began and I've been
working off and on ever since that's so
important I love hearing stories about
that because I feel like the only way we
can keep making new and interesting
films is if the people who have the
opportunity to like throw their weight
around in a way help other people out
there and give them opportunities you
just name dropped so many people so I'm
just curious of all of them is there any
specific advice or other help in
addition to spielberg with like someone
taking you under their wing in a respect
that is really stuck with you well you
can't really expect that and you
to have the work that delivers I was
lucky enough that the writing was of
equality that you know you can't just
appeal to one person you have to keep
delivering and it being something that
you can be proud of and you're not
trying to write what's popular what's
what's going to make you money what you
know you have to have a passion for it
because I wrote four years before I ever
got high I wrote for 20 years from the
time I was 12 years old before I got
hired on amazing stories and I did it
because I couldn't not write and then
the writing read to led to directing and
producing but I think it's you know it's
not just the right people and the right
time but the material is the most
important thing and with good material
that somebody thinks they can sell you
can get representation and that opens
doors to people has been well it just
has been really nice and the interviews
we've had how often we do hear stories
of at least in the genre space of really
well-known filmmaker and film makers
helping to crack the door for younger
talents yeah if you come across
something really great yeah you know
it's really a wonderful opportunity to
bring them on board something if you
know on him on masters of horror the the
selling point was all of them were
name-brand horror directors but there
was young lucky McKee who had made a
movie that all of us were really
impressed by and so he came on board to
do one so we kind of knighted him given
what you said before about putting you
know story over an opportunity just to
make money I'm really curious to know
what your take is on just like the
general horror theatrical landscape
right now because we've got I mean
really most of the films out there
there's some original gems I don't want
to kind of you know brush those away but
there's a lot of franchises and reboots
and retconning happening so what's just
kind of like your overview of where we
stand though well you know it's it's a
very broad umbrella the horror genre has
never been more successful and greater
or shittier you know there
me the nadir of horror cinema is the
franchise and you know this is a guy who
wrote and directed critters too and
directed cycle 4 but you know it's it's
depressing when it's a bunch of movies
with numbers made for teenagers because
in my travels around the world going to
festivals genre festivals all around the
world you discover it's only the United
States where horror is aimed at
teenagers and you know college kids in
the like it's a really valid
storytelling form and format and the
horror genre should be incredibly adult
and sophisticated and is in a lot of
ways the theatrical experience is tough
because the studio's the big studios
based in the United States think that
they're for kids and they only can sell
what they know how to sell and what they
know how to sell is what they've sold
before so if something new and striking
comes along it becomes more difficult so
you've got VOD but how do you separate
the wheat from the chaff and for me it's
been going to these festivals and seeing
them it's listening to podcasts like
yours and and people like shockwaves and
other places that the talk about the new
films and find out about the great stuff
so it's an exciting time for horror and
a depressing time and the same while
it's making more money than ever but you
also have creative people you know Andre
over a doll and coralie Farah and
Arielle Starr doing very distinctive how
did you just pronounce her name because
I'm gonna pocket that and remember
everything I constantly talk about her
and I always say it wrong
Coralie farsi ah Coralie fajr yeah she
was on our podcast actually we did a
Skype podcast to Paris with her I think
revenge is just a great great movie and
amazing it's the first feature yeah you
know it's so confident and stylistically
unified and fantastically compelling
I feel like now we need to bump up our
usual end question so you like revenge
is there anything else out there that's
really catching your eye whether it's
kind of like an under-the-radar film TV
show or even like a book or anything in
the genre yeah I I'm just reading horror
store right now by Grady Hendrix who is
great who wrote my best friend's
exorcism which I thought was a terrific
book and it sounds like a teen franchise
movie but it's a really smart book but I
also think the perfection that Richard
shepherded is fantastic
and of course I've worked with Steven
Weber several times so I loved seeing
him in anything so yeah there's a lot of
really interesting stuff out there you
know we've got our Twilight zones back
we've got our black mirrors and and all
kinds of anthology stuff out there as
well so it's a fertile time and the more
original horror stuff whether it's not
for two or the other shows that are
around the most original stuff is
happening in television and streaming
and much less so in in theaters well I
mean you talk about the perfection which
it wasn't made for streaming but that's
where I found a home and that's
obviously this this force in the
industry right now that's kind of
changing how everything operates how has
like your perspective in your creative
process been altered by the rise of
streaming well there are more outlets
but it's just as hard to get something
off the ground
I think streaming is a great option
because the theatrical experience has
been so dominated by theme park
attractions by by giant Marvel had apt
Asians and 200 million-dollar movies I
think the option of having Hulu and Vudu
and Netflix and Apple TV and all these
different sources is great would I
rather see it on an 80-foot theater
screen with surround sound and 400
people in the audience
absolutely horror his best shared as is
comedy and it's a communal experience
fear is much more frightening when it's
spreading throughout an
surrounding you but the option to have
it and you know I've got a 70 inch 4k TV
with surround sound at home and it's the
closest thing I can get to the
theatrical experience like that so I
think it's a great time the material
that I write does not really change
because it's aimed more at streaming or
theatrical or or broadcast it's just
more options to get that material out
there you know nightmare cinema is the
smallest budget I've ever worked on and
we're getting a limited theatrical in a
couple of dozen cities at the same day
and datas as on-demand so it's it's just
a complicated time for film and
distribution so nightmare cinema is an
anthology and I adored the anthology
format when we had VHS in the spotlight
for a little while I I mean I was just
rooting for it not just to be something
that we discuss in a room like this but
Direction stream appeal so has that been
a little bit of a challenge for you when
you were first getting it off the ground
was there any like oh no I don't know if
people are gonna be open to another
anthology movie well it didn't start
that way it started as my follow-up to
masters of horror I wanted to do an
international Howard Lee weekly TV
series and each one of them done in a
different country and my ambition seems
to have farther reach than the studios
and networks ambitions
so then I thought you know well let's do
it as a series of feature films
nightmare cinema presents John Carpenter
is so-and-so
tobe Hooper is whatever Wes Craven's
whatever were you hey kid amaura's
whatever but even that was a little too
ambitious so it took years to get this
off the ground deciding to do it as a
feature film with five stories and
anthology but my history is it's never
been easy to sell when we did masters of
horror no one was looking for a horror
anthology but I said we can have John
Carpenter and tobe Hooper and all these
people and so my history with anthology
is deep my first job was writing for
amazing stories I did an episode
Tales from the Crypt we did masters of
horror I did Freddy's nightmares you
know I've been a part of lots and lots
of well amazing stories being the first
job was was kind of a incredible and it
had a similar philosophy as masters of
horror and nightmare cinema would just
get the best directors you can find and
set them free you know and that's kind
of where I learned it you talk about
this long journey to finally getting it
made and it's many iterations ultimately
what were the steps that you had to take
to finally get it funded to get it made
what was what made you able to cross the
threshold after those years dropping the
pilot price getting a tighter and
tighter budget to the point where you
know it's well I don't think it's
possible we could lose money on this
because it's a collection of filmmakers
who are familiar there's international
appeal there's a director from Japan a
director from Latin America director
from the UK and then two US directors so
we put together a package that you could
make a really high-quality movie at the
price of a good TV show and so I think
that was the final place we went to a
company that was run by the former head
of Warner Brothers and Columbia and the
former head of the eight films to die
for series of movies so it was Kourtney
Solomon and Mark Canton their company
Cinna Liu and they're the ones who found
the funding for it and saw the
commercial potential
whenever do interviews at junkies I
always ask these would you rather
questions and I'm curious your take on
one of them would you rather have enough
money and not enough time or enough time
and not enough money if you have enough
money that buys you enough time but more
time would allow you greater flexibility
and greater
opportunity to flex the cinematic
muscles and the tools given you but more
money would buy you the same thing so if
you have ten million dollars versus five
million dollars and you were going to do
a twenty day shoot and you can do a
forty day shoot there you go I can't
wait until I ask that to the next person
that figures out that that's actually a
very real answer I also wanted to ask
you a lot about the the wraparound
component because that's another thing
about anthology feature films that
really fascinates me because you know
I've seen some work and some haven't and
you also want to give your filmmakers
the luxury to kind of like do their
things so at what point in the process
are you writing the rap around what are
you explaining to them about it and I
mean obviously working with Mickey
Rourke is just mind-blowing to me it was
mind-blowing to me too before during it
after in this case I wanted to give them
free rein I did not write the wrap
arounds or even the concept for the
wraparound until all of the scripts had
been written and then we had to figure
out the order in which those stories
would play I knew I wanted it to be set
in a movie theater an abandoned movie
theater and but the concept of what it
was and it's still not fully formed in
this because there is still the hope
that we will be making a TV series from
this and at the very least a sequel
Ogada franchise but the idea of making
the Mickey Rourke projectionists
character sort of a guard of a well of
experience or horrific experiences that
had been melded into the movie theater
screen as he puts it I'm the curator of
a hundred years of nightmares trapped in
a silver screen that never forgets I
just like that concept that any story
fits into that so all of the scripts
were were developed independently and
then it was just up to
me to figure out a way to link them
without having them necessarily have to
thematically match one another so the
wrap arounds were shot after the fact
I'm curious you know we've talked about
franchising a little bit what do you
think
pound for pound is the franchise that
did best and maintaining quality in
horror or has done that's because many
are still going yeah well usually the
longer they go the less good they are
but you know psycho went for four and I
shouldn't mention anything I was a part
of it's hard to say I think they all
peter out after two or three I mean once
you get to three four and five the
returns are usually not very good so I
mean you're putting me on the spot here
and I'm having a tough time coming up
well I'll give you in a mind okay I
think there's not a bad Evil Dead movie
and the Evil Dead TV series also kicks
ass good just talking about it before
everyone out there knows I'm obsessed
with this oh good yeah ash versus evil
it's so good I would also throw scream
in there but I know scream three is hit
or miss for some folks I'm sure yeah but
I don't know Wes really put his finger
on something that worked really well and
and I would say that's good for is
better than three you're right for the
opening of four will be ingrained in my
mind for life I quite like yeah I'm
waiting for that to have it sort of like
Jennifer's body moment where we come
back to a ten years later and people
like actually that was pretty fun people
are starting to talk about for a little
more lately I heard them talk about it
on shockwaves the other day so I just
applaud them for taking chances at the
end yeah it's like that ending I didn't
expect it and emma roberts owns it and
here we are talking about a teen horror
franchise so well yeah i mean i do
wonder it do you think that scream kind
of put us on that path in the state's
more dramatically it's like i know that
was what a lot of the franchise's were
still geared at before but on the Friday
the 13th franchise certainly
and it on and on and on and on and on
feels like after scream they like
specifically like from scream through
like the late-2000s it was all like like
get the high school kids in the theater
every Friday night
well scream became the first of the rest
self-referential as it were true
actually Friday the 13th part 6 is by
far my favorite because it does it did
what scream did years before yeah it
sends it up it's really genuinely funny
and clever and self-referential you know
I love a line with one of the kids as as
they're being attacked by Jason and what
were you going to be when you grew up
boy camp 3 had some weird rough
self-referential stuff I didn't get that
far thrown in there pretty fun did you
ever say you wanted to be anything when
you grew up other than a journalist or a
filmmaker I wanted to be a cartoonist my
father was a school artist who had
created a couple of comic strips in the
life but never was able to make his
living at it and so I inherited some of
his artistic ability and I thought I
would make animated cartoons which is
what I really wanted to do as a kid and
I drew until I was about 12 years old
drawing was my thing and then I started
writing at 12 and I kind of abandoned
the the art for typing do you have any
edge to get into animation though like
especially like horror animation I feel
like there's a like there's an untapped
welder yeah I think there's a great
opportunity for it I don't know I really
like working with a cast and crew and
being on a set and making it take place
you know getting your hands dirty and
doing it and you know sitting in a
writers room is one thing and then
sitting in a room full of computers with
animators
I don't know that that would give me the
same kind of joy as I get what I'm on a
set surrounded by really creative crew
people and actors and all of that do you
stand that passion for animation shaped
your approach to storytelling in any way
it probably did I don't know that's a
good question how bad it did because of
the energy of animation and the idea
that anything can happen in animation
but also you can't be boring you know
because anything can happen in animation
you don't waste any time
and I certainly maybe it was from that
that that I came to the realization that
any scene in a movie or any scene in a
story should be compelling whether it's
an action scene or not you can have a
dialogue scene but it better be really
great dialogue or have a momentum or a
reality or a sense of humor or a snap to
it
that keeps you going if you're flipping
channels and you end up on a scene in a
movie every one of those scenes should
be enough to captivate you to stay with
it from that you have such an unusual
background where I see kind of like
everything coming together from like
your your drawing when you were younger
like even all the way to like film
publicity like you understanding you
that when you make a movie after all
these years is there any single
department for making a movie that you
wish you could learn more about well all
of it
you know everything keeps evolving which
is what's exciting about the genre not
just the genre but filmmaking itself the
technology of it is completely different
from when I started and it was thirty
five-millimeter and everything had to go
through a lab there was no such thing as
computer-generated visual effects you
know everything was latex and Karo syrup
and all that stuff and I loved practical
effects and we've got some great ones in
this movie and masters of horror we had
K and B doing that and but the digital
effects are really great but recently I
did a couple of episodes of Once Upon a
Time totally outside my comfort zone
which is you know I want to keep
evolving but I worked on a
they called the Zeus stage where it's a
stage where everything you're surrounded
by a blue or a green screen and there is
no set it's put in in post-production
it's all computer-generated and yet you
can move your cameras anywhere and on
your monitors you see a sketch of what
you're going to see in the end and so
that technology directing is still the
thing I'm most excited about but all of
it because it's at the center of the
hurricane it's the eye of the hurricane
you have to have some knowledge of
cinematography of lighting of music of
performance and all of those things so
that is the job that I want to keep
learning more about as I do it I feel
like every time I start out I feel new
at it again well one of the things you
certainly have a lot of experience
directing is Stephen King and you know
we've talked about franchises and genre
cycles and there's also brand cycles in
the King brand as as hot as it was ten
years ago taking sources yeah yeah I
mean what is it you you know you
obviously directed The Shining series
are very tight into that material what
was it like seeing the doctor sleep
trailer seeing this new cycle of king
well it's interesting the doctor sleep
trailer having recreated scenes from the
Kubrick Shining which King hated it was
very interesting because you know Mike
Flanagan has has worked so often with
King as well yeah it's a it's a surprise
to see that but it's exciting I love
Steve is seeing Steve King have an even
bigger place in the Sun right now or in
the shade but the fact that people are
remaking things of his why mean we did
the shining didn't consider it a remake
because it was so far removed what had
been done before but technically I guess
you would call it a remake but to be at
a point in someone's career that started
in in the 1970s for him to see these
things taking shape again but the fact
that he still as active
ballistas ever before and the new work
is being adapted to two different media
as well it's thrilling to me you know
he's got a voice that I think is why
he's had so many decades of success you
you read Stephen King you know it's
Stephen King and to have been able to
work with him we have similar
backgrounds there's a few years between
us but we come from a similar generation
we grew up in similar circumstances in a
broken home
our mothers raised us and and not much
money or anything you know very
blue-collar circumstances and to just
see that that affected him so deeply
creatively and as a human being I think
the audience identifies with that and I
think that's what is so key to to who he
is and why his material strikes such a
chord with its audience agree more real
quick I just listened to your interview
you just had with him and it was really
wonderful
yeah his first podcast years but it was
to celebrate the 25th anniversary of the
stand yeah so I was thrilled to be able
to get him and I hadn't hadn't had a
conversation with him in a couple of
years so it was really nice to be able
to do that yeah it's a great interview I
highly recommend this is a big question
but having you know having known him and
worked with him so much I mean there's
bound to be more adaptations on the way
especially after it and dr. sleep comes
out and everybody else gobbles up more
rights for a filmmaker who has never
adapted a piece of his material before
what is the number one piece of advice
you would give them that it's not about
the monster in the closet but it's about
the family that owns the home with the
monster in the closet couldn't have been
said better that voice you talked about
I mean even even in your podcast your
conversation you can hear that
personality that he writes with and how
he speaks
it's the humanity of it that's what
makes him popular it's not the blood
guts you know it's it's a voice he's you
know gooble gobble one of us but he he
really is not the uber wealthy superstar
writer producer screenwriter now he's
just Stephen King writer and he has no
pretensions you know what you see with
with King is what you get and he's one
of the most genuine and generous people
I've ever known outside of the ones you
worked on together when adaptation do
you think gets that spirit I love the
dead zone I love misery stand by me is
one of my favorites it's not a horror
movie but it's so unbelievably powerful
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time absolutely I'm with you on that and
of course Kerry being the first it's
still kicks it's amazing
so there's so many really good ones yeah
I feel like it's about time to bring the
dead zone back to ya I'd be interested
in seeing what a young filmmaker would
bring to that you know it was so not a
Cronenberg style story and you know
before that film the brood was really
the most human of kronenberg's movies
and this was not just human but
emotional and heart-wrenching and just
it's great I would love to see what a
modern take would be on that I would be
curious as well is there any other novel
of his that has yet to be adapted or
another film out there that you think
like like now's the time bring this back
because as precious as I am about some
of my favorite movies out there I've
become more open than ever to the idea
of remaking things because at least it
spreads the love whether it's for that
specific story or bringing people back
to the source material well I'm very
curious to see what Josh Boone does with
the stage yes reboot you know it's gonna
be a 10-hour CBS all access thing
and you know a lot more money than we
had when we did the stand but josh is a
really great filmmaker a really terrific
writer and a total devotee of Stephen
King and we've had a couple
conversations and and he's a huge fan of
the miniseries that we did and so I'm
dying to see what you do with a real
budget - I'm serious what kind of
questions did he ask you during our
conversation it was really not so much
questions as a conversation and and just
I think he he wanted to know that it was
okay with me but you know it was just
kind of getting to know one another and
kind of telling me some of the things
that he was planning and and he you know
it was it was really just conversation
about King and who he is and what the
material is and how human it was and
that sort of thing it was it was more an
appreciation of King's book and of King
as a human being an artist than it was a
do you have any advice for me sir I'm
also excited you mentioned the budget
but it's also the the limitations you
know CBS all access it's it's been a
point of contention but they've they've
gone lean into a more r-rated vibe with
Twilight Zone very much and you talked
on your podcast with King about how you
couldn't have you know like an open dead
eye are these these ABC limits yes we
did it anyway cited for that element -
yeah I'm looking forward to it not
having the censorship issues we had to
deal with it and that was a thing with
masters of horror you know it was so
completely uncensored other than the one
week a episode that wasn't aired that
when it sold to Lionsgate and NBC as
fear itself I basically left the project
because of the interface the philosophy
is these people are doing this because
they want to do something their way and
that's the whole point of the show and
when you've got NBC notes from NBC notes
from Lionsgate notes from advertisers
it's not what we set out to do that's
something I love about anthologies those
are sort of circle it all back is the
the budgets are usually so low that you
get that wonderful freedom filmmakers
are there any studios out there that you
think afford the filmmakers that freedom
because I mean even bringing up Josh
Boone obviously I still have New Mutants
on my brain which I saw that trailer and
I'm like that's the horror superhero
movie that I really wanted and clearly
that ran into some complications so like
if you had advice for somebody who kind
of has like your creative mindset and
wants to do their thing would you steer
them away from the big-budget pictures
or is there still opportunity there I
would never steer anybody away from a
good paying job and a career move you
know that's it there's nothing wrong
with that it's still you know I never
thought I would direct episodes of
Pretty Little Liars and and Once Upon a
Time and I loved it I found myself
surrounded by creative people doing the
best work they know how and using tools
I'd never used before and in once upon a
time the most emotional scene I've ever
directed is in that TV show so there is
artistry in filmmaking and even the
giant Marvel franchises and the like you
know you you get James Gunn doing what
he did and he got two versions to do it
and there'll be a third but without him
well no it's with him well yeah
guardians of the galaxy to me is the
best Marvel movie ever you know I think
it's crazy because it had a voice and it
had a filmmaker at the helm who wrote
and directed it and had a vision you can
do it you know Blum House people who
work with them say that they are given
full creative control despite the fact
that most of their movies now are team
franchise oriented movies but they are
making money and it allows the horror
genre to maintain a vivacity that that
it doesn't always get its and then
sometimes you get something like what
Jordan Peele is doing at subverts all
the expectations act
get out was a total GameChanger a really
great movie and won Oscars
respectability the first time our jammer
did that since 1990 it's gonna change I
just have all the yeah I have all the
faith in the world that it's gonna
change between like that in one respect
and then what black panther is achieved
i feel like we're starting to see little
cracks where different types of material
are getting that kind of notice more
diversity in in gender and ethnicity in
you know just nationality all of those
things make for a broader canvas of
stories to be told and and that was the
point of doing nightmare cinema as a
series and and as i'm not constantly
trying to bring it back to nightmare
cinema but making the point that you
know there there is a diversity of
visions of cinematic visions on display
and i want to go deeper i want to get
you know we have one of the writers is a
woman from mexico city i want to get
women i want to get african-american i
want to get you know every kind of input
that i can i don't know if you can say
this but should you get to make another
installment is there anybody like a
dream person you have your eye on for
the next one absolutely i would love to
get karan Kusama involved I think the
invitation is one of the best movies
I've ever seen and I would love to get
her nurse Dickerson to come in and do
that we work together on masters Ammar
and he's a great filmmaker and a great
guy and another totally new vision who
started out as a director of photography
first for Spike Lee so I mean just in
the diverse category those are two
people who I think are really just great
filmmakers I would be very much in for
that I have one very specific question
for your portion actually was working on
the score for it because it feels super
sinister at times and then it almost
gets like a playful vibe a little bit at
the end so I'm just curious about
designing that yeah like a little
there's this part where they're I don't
want to spoil anything there's a part
where you
know that there's a little more urgency
and they're running through chasing
through yeah and like I I kind of almost
like perked up when I heard that I liked
it yeah it was an interesting choice
Richard band who scored the reanimate
her way back when a great great composer
and he did one of my scores for masters
of horror and and also worked with
Stuart Gordon a lot so he did that one
and Joe Dante's segment as well as the
wrap arounds and I was surprised when I
heard that but and I wasn't sure how I
felt about it
but I realized you know it's a kind of
energy that you don't expect it is kind
of almost a xylophone element to to the
music and it's not traditional chase
music and at first my temptation was to
give it a more familiar propulsion but
then I realized now this works
I really like where this is going
especially because it becomes one of the
more sentimental maybe the only
sentimental emotional what well the the
David Slade one's very emotional but not
at all sentimental and so it gave us a
good transition to go someplace from
that to elsewhere yeah that's choice how
do you mention David Slade and I his I
don't know I saw this first a year ago
at Fantasia oh you didn't know you were
there our world premiere yeah it was
lovely and he's really like I don't know
it has that kind of nightmare quality
that sticks in your side and just like I
could now see myself having nightmares
in the palette and tone of that Porsche
how did you get him involved and like
how did he come up with that segment did
you work with him on it or was he just
like I've got this idea let's run it
well I went to him you know I knew him
from the Masters of Horror dinners that
he had come to and and I really loved
Hannibal and I loved hard candy and I
just thought this was somebody I would
love to work with and so all of the
other four film makers were the first
one I didn't go to anybody else
and and I knew he had a very distinctive
vision and when I went to him he had
something that he'd been working on this
way to egress they developed as a
feature film okay and never got it off
the ground and so when I went to him he
said yeah I've got an idea and told me
the story and gave me a 14 page script
which was by far the shortest one and so
how do you go from a feature script to
14 feet and I'd the only change I said
was if you could add a scene does this
is a little too short for what we're
doing but if there's a scene that you
took out by being too ruthless go for it
but I knew he was a stylist and when I
read the script I didn't know what the
movie was going to be like because as
you know so much of it has to do with
the style and how its told and the
visuals it's not in the words it's not
in the descriptions but knowing David's
work and and what he plus he had just
come back from doing his first black
mirror episode in black and white and so
uh I'm doing this in black and white and
shot it with cameras that only shoot
black and white I didn't tell the
producers the other producers but no I
he he I gave him full rein on that other
than then just we need but yeah it's
it's very haunting it does feel like you
are stepping into the nightmare of
someone who is losing their sanity yeah
it's like a quicksand into someone
else's nightmare exactly yeah it's very
disturbing yeah it's a real standout and
you're right it's visual it's not though
it's just you slowly or like what are my
eyes doing here exactly yeah we are
winding down now okay
we kind of did ask our one go to but
should we ask the other one I think it's
a yeah we have to now don't break rules
for me a very important thing that
happens in here is this question do you
have any pets I know
we have pets but I've had a couple of
Italian Greyhounds in a row both of them
passed away and it's just been a little
bit still not quite ready but I'm on the
verge of getting a night I am a total
animal person and I love dogs I'm a
vegan because I love animals
you know not for health reasons although
that's beneficial as well but I'm a
total animal person I feel like for
whatever reason it just has always
seemed like like a horror lovers and pet
lovers go hand and hand oddly we have to
had anyone yet be like no I don't do
animals yeah there might have been one
person that said that and it was
strictly because I believe it was an
actor that said that and it's like like
I'm out and about making movies I can't
have a pair it is tough because you know
you almost never shoot in LA
nightmare cinema being an exception to
the rule everything I've done in the
last several years has either been in
Vancouver or Toronto or another state
but I it seems like over my entire
career I probably shot more into in
Vancouver than anywhere else is there
any new place with like an emerging film
industry that you think well Georgia of
course is big hopefully not for much
longer in the wake of these new laws
might have been what made the question
come to mind yeah yeah so you know I
hope that it comes back to LA there's a
reason it's the center of production the
weather is one thing it's the thing that
brought everybody out here but now it's
the deepest pool of talent whether it's
actors or a crew or artisans they have
all of the facilities all of the studios
are based here and it's heartbreaking to
see it leave for monetary reasons but
the industry was born in New Jersey and
it grew up and came of age in Los
Angeles and I was born in Los Angeles
and a devoted Angelino and a
I want my industry to come home I like
the sound of backpack so we must say
goodbye now but before we tune out is
there anywhere in particular you want to
direct our viewers to see more of your
work whether it's social media or your
your other podcast well I am on Facebook
and it's me not somebody saying it but
there's also a post-mortem on Facebook
post mortem with McGarrett on Facebook
and the podcast is available at all the
usual places through Fangoria but it's
on iTunes or Apple podcasts now and
Google Play and Spotify in all the usual
places on Twitter at post-mortem mg and
post-mortem Graham on Instagram so check
all that out everyone actually a bunch
of the old interviews I did the Z
Channel interviews and my post mortem TV
series is on McGarrett interviews calm
really that's an actual resource yeah
that's a lot for you guys to check out
and you should do so and also again
nightmare cinema June 21st keep an eye
out Haley briefly working everyone find
you on the internet and find me on
instagram at haystack mcgroove e and on
twitter at Haley found and I am at P
Nemiroff on Twitter and Instagram and I
am ashamed of myself that I'm wearing
this t-shirt never asked a single
hocus-pocus we gotta go I mean that take
the box for me already I'm just happy to
hear you say that all right guys you
have officially survived the witching
hour